[Musique]
la tue tout doucement 250 milliards de
morts par an c'est la merdique est aussi
un crab
astrologique la cigarette non seulement
ça tu ça coûte cher et puis ça pue la
nicotine te colle au Doig tes cheve sent
le cendrier pendant des
mois fume fume cette cigarette gr de
vieux sont des conseils de
médecine pour mon magazine fume fume et
puis oublie les détergents qu'il y a
dedans les bénéfices de l'État la marche
de
[Musique]
lais
responsabilisé on Ta prvous c'est écrit
si tu vas crever ne viens pas faire un
procès sur un fusi ou un lancequette ne
manque que cette phrase obsolète faites
attention ne tirez pas vous allez
sûrement faire du mal à un
gars fume fume cette cigarette gr de
vieux clop sur des conseils de
[Musique]
médecine fume et puis oublie les
détergents qu'il y a dedans les
bénéfices de l'État la marque la
[Musique]
SE lesit jaunes foncé et gourd du roi
des mots Serge ginbourg savait déjà que
ce poison emmènerait leur propriétaire
tout droit au cimetière il y a 50 ans le
16 mai mourit Dango il devait fumer des
GO d' nerveux long et sec courit dans
les cordes comme
[Musique]
Z
F cette
cigarette
[Musique]
cons
la
cette la
Crette la cigarette ou la
[Applaudissements]
cigarette au début des années 80 je me
souviens des soirées où ambiance chos et
les mecs rentr au pied le regard Frid la
sal rou autour du bras sur la tte
sur tout le monde se l des CER concours
deoutimovis je te propose voyage dans le
VI planète Marseille je
dan je
je
[Musique]
danse je
danse je danse jusqu'à ce que la soirée
une Bagard au fond et tout le monde s
parille que céit nul que sa samedi
d'près on revenait tellement qu'on
semmerdait j'entends encore le rire des
filles qui assistaient au bai des Rena
sur le parking à l'intérieur pour elle
céit rose oh cousine tu Danes ou je
t'explose voilà comment tu s'ag gravé en
un quart d'heure le frère rppliqué oh
combi tu parles à ma sœur viens avec moi
on va se filer tête à tête je vais te
fumer derrière les cpray et tout
s'arranger ou se régler à la danse dis t
fes qu' a aucune chance et les filles
mes chaussures Brill tour je brille je
te Bou si tu te rabill et moi je danse
le M même les voitures c'était le 8 73
GM 12 petit du Grand Paillou à la plus
grosse miette la main sur le volant avec
la par sole sur le par arrière et Val éc
gros sur mon père
lanepo
[Musique]
mag
maris
merci d'être avec nous ce soir new star
flasher action club nous sommes ensem
pour une super soirée de bonheur music
avec un grand concours de danse ce soir
des cadeaux il y aura des
t-shirts
peluch la technique c'est
mich c'est la fête c'est
parti ah super soirée on s'amuse
F
je danse le M vous allez comprendre
écoutez bien je danse le M pas chemise
ouverte chaîn un or qui brille des
gestes l ils prenaient leur temps pour
enchaîner les passes qu'ils avaient
élaboré dans leur quartier c'était
vraiment trop beau un mec assuré tout le
monde crier ah oui la piste s'enfamé et
tous les yeux converg les différen et
des rire éclaté beaucoup disaient que
not soirée était sauvage et qu'il
fallait entrer avec une batte ou une
hache c'était les rag des jaloux et quoi
qu'on en dise nous on s'amusait beaucoup
aujourd'hui encore on peut entendre des
filles
[Musique]
dire je danse le
M je danse
M
[Musique]
rap
br
su
hist
[Musique]
deeoasad cab R
brasir
[Musique]
tioas
queenderasirasir
[Musique]
gu Rio
de maravos
[Musique]
asileir
que
aprenderer
se
brasir
[Musique]
Rio
de
iden brasileer brile meu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci merci c'était gentil
vraiment gentil j'espère que vous vous
dormez très très bien aujourd'hui mais
si quelque chose se passe entre nous et
vous dans ça fait rien ça fait rien il
faut venir demain Olympia et parler avec
nous qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce que
nous nous avons la solution pour presque
tous les problèmes part tout parce que
tout c'est trop demain Olympia les
étoiles Rand Louis Antoine
[Musique]
merci merci
mie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avons
[Musique]
when she walk she like a that S so cool
and S so gently that when she pass
pass
oh
can he tell her he loves
her yes she would give his heart
gladly but each day when she walks to
the sea she looks straight ahead not
he and and young and Lely the girl from
evening my goes walking and when she
passes smiles but she doesn't see
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on dirait de l'italien mais c'est c'est
du Brésilien c'est astr
Gilberto
[Musique]
era um era dois era 100 era o mundo
chegando e ninguém que soubesse que eu
sou violeiro que me desse o amor ou
dinheiro era um era dois era ass e
vieram para me perguntar você de onde
vai de onde vem diga logo que tem para
contar parado no meio do mundo pensei
chegar meu momento olhei pro mundo e nem
via nem sombra nem sol nem
vento qu Dar AG eUea para
cant
quem me Dar Agora eu tivesse a Viola pr
cantar qu me Dar Agora eu ti Viola para
cantar quem me der Agora eu tiess Viola
para
cantar
era um era dois era 100 era o mundo
chegando ninguém quez que eu sou
violeiro que meu amor dinheiro era um
era dois era e vieram para perguntar
você de onde vai de onde vem diga logo o
que tem contar parado no meio do mundo
pensei chegar meu momento olhei mundo e
nem via nem sombra nem sol nem
[Musique]
e me Dar Agora eu tivess a Viola pr
cantar qu me Agora eu ti Viola para
cantar qu me Agora eu tiola para
cantar me Dar Agora eutive Viola para
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cantar
ah tu en verras d'autre ma fille des
gars
puissants avec du sex à
pile fais attention au marioles à chaque
instant te fis pas leur bagno à leur
[Musique]
diamant
dufur bien sage les hommes faut toujours
s'en méfier quelque fois ça fait bon
usage
l'amour ça pardonne
pas ça peut durer des mois des jours 5
minutes
quelquefois
l'amour ça pardonne
pas ça peut durer des mois des jours 5
minutes
quelquefis on va leur enlever les piles
on va leur mettre des fessés on en dira
que les filles c'est pas comme les
poubes dans les magazines des fesses on
leur fera les dansents noir on regardera
leurs épinesend comme des
perchoir
ant un ver et sans regret au désespoir
et à l'excès un homme de moins 10 de
retrouver
l'amour ça pardonne
pas ça peut durer des mois des jours 5
minutes
quelquefois
l'amour ça pardonne
pas ça peut durer des des jours 5
minutes
quelquefois prends ton
[Musique]
sa avec ton
épuisette viens avec moi à lappelleche
Chalom la pê
àalom un beau
sentimental un vrai
héros s'en va au bal agité
noolo
l'amour ça paronne
pas ça peut durer des mois des jours 5
minutes
quelquefois
l'amour ça pardonne
pas ça peut durer des mois des jours 5
minutes
quelquefois
l'amour ça pardonne
pas ça peut durer des mois des jours 5
minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelquefois
[Musique]
what
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
end
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
فك
وانك معمر
ين ما عندك ما
تزي
موالفمحص
[Musique]
ونارقلونوني بي على راي خوني
خلوني خلوني نبي على ظهري
خلوني خلوني
خلونيب خوني خلون
[Musique]
ه شوف الناس
كيفز شوف
الفل شوففش صفي وان اسمك
مب كان اللي ضحكته الدنيا وعطتله
بالحساب ما يبك
ويصبون خلوني خلوني نبكي على راي
وخلوني
خلوني خلوني نبكي على ظهري خلوني خلوني
خلوني خلوني
نبك
وخلوني
خلوني خوني نبك على
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
زه
خلوني خلوني خلوني نبك على راي
وخلوني
خلوني خون نبك على زه وخلون
خونون خلوني نبكي على
[Musique]
راخلونيلوني
خلوني
[Musique]
et ma télé est allumée et ma t là et
dire que ma journée est à peine
entaméemma tu m'as déjà scotché
canapé et m'astu vraiment des fois plus
belle que ta
[Musique]
main comment fais-tu pour être aussi sûr
de
toi s le pied mon quelque peu
etmasculé
et je t'en prie rend moi ma
virilité et ma vraiment plus belle
[Musique]
que et ma copine elle t'aime pas etemma
es bonne et ma pile va bientôt claquer
et ma comme le carage de
mes
et plus
[Musique]
queemmaemma
h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma va exploser et
matoitoi dire que pour toi j'aurais
gaché ma
santé par ici à me
soulager et M vraim P
[Musique]
ài
VI
[Musique]
marijemmaemmaemmaemmaemma I emmaya
emmayaya
[Musique]
emmaya
celles qui ont vu trois fois renman
celles qui ont pleuré
Balavoine celles qui faisait des exposé
sur l'APAR et sur
le celles qui ont envoyé du riz en
Éthiopie en Somalie celles qui
disait tu comprends
pas les filles de
1973 ans 30
ans les filles de
1973 ont 30 ans la
là celle qui pratiquait des susons dans
le cou de Cyril Caron celle qui
fusillait au Blanco les tables du lycée
carneau celle qui disait madame c'est
vrai
on na rien compris au sujet celle qui
s'appelait Estelle
Galois le F de
1973 on 30
[Musique]
ans les filles
73 30
ans